today is we're gonna call this I'm gonna
call today fig Friday I'm hot it
Christmas to be like a mini finger as
serious 50 and maybe not for her I think
like a month now about yeah we're bad we
are so I drove all around this parking
garage trying to find a place to park
and then I was like oh oh I see a spot
and Ed pulls in right next right in
front of me I couldn't believe is like
wait found you so we're about to get
some figs we gotta get it we gotta get
them all University Dining almost enough
we need to get a small snack first and
then we find the wings thank you sir
look at all these small snack options
medium snack smoked butterscotch lot
what top
one of those rules he just threw in a
vanilla latte
are you ready
okay we're at the Lego store now we're
about to get our bag peeling on we've
also got two other people here they were
here before us already feelings do you
know what those are I didn't even do
anything yet which ones you guys looking
for shark pretty much sure I mean space
man
no do you think it's that the offeree
oh yeah then maybe they've all freeze
chest piece oh wait that's long a big
dudes
okay well I don't have you know these in
any order no so there's a figure them
out
this is another one and okay circle
x-x-x
do you want hand because i'm gonna get
one yeah but you can take him first by
the way
and they were like $700 because there
weren't any that were actually there no
are you okay no I mean I looked at this
and I was like pretty good and then I
was like wait can you put your coffee
down and pull that out just so I can
everyone in the world can see it
turn sideways okay you have to help me
build this ya know if you built this
without you I would just break it right
in the garbage disposal
okay we're gonna
a search box we've exhausted all options
we still need a couple stressed out
all right it's time to put these
together I hope that we got them all
here's our checklist let's assemble
in here though it's for watching let me
know which one of these minifigures is
your favorite and if you have another
favorite from any other series let me
know which one that is
one of my absolute favorites is the
unicorn which was a few series ago and
also the costume Pig but out of this
series I love the shark I love the
little chunk scared taker the pig farmer
are you kidding me I got a couple extras
of those ones so that I could have a few
extra pigs I love this spaceman I love
the crutches guy I love a little indie
and I love the little baby minifigure I
love them all they're all really good
I'll see you guys the next video don't
forget to subscribe if you want to see
more videos and if you enjoyed this
video make sure you hit like and I'll
see you the next vid peace come on I'll
clean up my mess now so you ever baked a
cake using a blender before no Nick I
can't believe using a blender this is my
ground this is so awesome I really hope
this works I'm really hopeful